people in the middle of Putin's speech
yesterday Russia launched a rocket
attack against the southern city
Southern Ukrainian city rather of
hairson and officials there say it was a
deadly one six civilians killed schools
across Ukraine today have moved to
online lessons in fact all week saying
they are afraid of new Russian attacks
at the end of the one-year Mark of
fighting there and Charlie dagada is
going to take a look now at the war's
impact on one Ukrainian family and we do
warn you it's a story that includes
graphic images
Russian Rockets slammed into the
southern Port City of Curson on the day
world leaders were blaming each other
for escalating the war here
a year into the Invasion the estimated
number of dead and wounded on both sides
has reached more than 200 000.
knows firsthand the horrors of this war
it's been a really hard year he said
because when you lose everyone you're
left alone
we last spoke with him after that day
last year
when a rushing mortar tore into a crowd
of people trying to flee Urban outside
of Kiev this image of a family struck
down shocked the world he told us then
he realized it was his own family when
it came up on Twitter
I recognize my children even though
their faces were hidden he said I was
able to recognize them by their clothing
their backpacks and the suitcase his
wife Tatiana his son 18 year old Makita
nine-year-old Elisa Who Loved To Dance
he returned home after Russians were
forced to retreat revealing a trail of
death and destroy production at the time
you said
it should be evidence of a war crime do
you still feel that way
those soldiers who killed my family have
died but there will be punishment to the
leadership of Russia he's given away
most of their belongings to those who
need it most he finds some consolation
helping neighbors rebuild their homes
and their lives it gives me a sense of
kindness he said it makes it possible to
continue living I can't help my family
but I can at least give some help to
others
he's training to be a medic now he's
taken military training Urban con fat
combat he says the Russians try to
retake those neighborhoods he's ready to
fight back
Gail
Charlie jacket and Ukraine thank you